احييكم ونستمر مشاهدينا في تغطيه اخر
الاخبار التي وردت في النشره السابقه في
العواجل من لاهاي ومن موسكو وايضا من كييف
قضاه في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في لهاي
اصدر امر اعتقال ضد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين طبعا على خلفيه حرب روسيا
في اوكرانيا اتهموا بوتين بارتكاب جرائم
حرب في اوكرانيا كما اصدر قضاه المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه امر اعتقال ضد مفوضه
حقوق الاطفال في روسيا كانت طبعا الامم
المتحده قالت في وقت سابق ان موسكو
تنتهكوا قواعد حمايه الاطفال واتهمتها
ايضا بترحيل الاطفال القصري
من جهتها قالت الخارجيه الروسيه قبل قليل
قالت انه ليس هناك اي قيمه تذكر لمذكره
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لاعتقال الرئيس
بوتين وهي وصفتها بالباطله قانونيا كما
اشارت الخارجيه الروسيه على لسان المتحدثه
باسمها ماريا خروفه الى ان لا صلاحيات
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه على موسكو
باعتبارها ليست عضوا فيها
من جهه اخرى قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
مذكره الاعتقال بحق بوتين ما هي الا
البدايه
على كل المزيد معنا من موسكو مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد
الجواد اذا بحسب تصريحات الرسميه الروسيه
هذا القرار لا قيمه له بمعنى اخر نفهم ان
روسيا لن تتحرك الان باي اتجاه
مساء الخير ميسون نعم بالفعل قرار لا قيمه
له كما تحدثت موسكو ولن يمس طبعا بالداخل
الروسي ولا بالرئيس الروسي باعتبار ان
موسكو ليست عضوان في هذه المحكمه طبعا هذا
ما تتحدث عنه الخارجيه الروسيه التي اضافت
بانهم كانوا على علم بمثل هذا القرار قبل
ايام من صدوره طبعا التحليلات السياسيه في
البلاد ميسون بعض صدور هذا القرارات بعد
صدور هذا القرار اتجهت نحو الحديث بانها
محاوله غربيه للتعتيم ولفت الانتباه من
قضيه الزياره الصينيه والرئيس الصيني الى
موسكو خلال ايام في العشرين من الشهر
الجاري لذلك طبعا هذا القرار لم تقمه
موسكو من ارضه بعض يعني كما يتحدث
القائمون والخيار الوحيد للرد عليه هو
ببعض التصريحات للخارجيه كما سمعنا طبعا
ميسون يعني هذا القرار يمس بقضيه الاطفال
واقامه في مناطق مختلفه وابرصها في شبه
جزيره القرم حسب ما يتحدث لكن طبعا من
الداخل الروسي هناك اصوات علت خلال الايام
القادمه عندما تم الحديث ونشر معلومات حول
حول احتماليه صدور مثل هذا القرار وهذه
التقارير التي تحدثت عن هذا الموضوع بان
هذا الشيء لا يمس للواقع باي شيء طبعا من
يعرف هذه الارض بشكل جيد يعرف القوانين
الصارمه جدا بما يخص قضيه الاطفال لذلك
طبعا اقامه معسكرات تحت مسمى طبعا اي
تدريبات او اي معسكرات طلابيه او شعبيه
لدى الجميع هو امر عار عن الصحه كما تتحدث
الحكومه هنا في موسكو
على القوانين الموجوده هناك عبد الجواد
اسمح لي ان انتقل الان الى مراسلنا ايضا
الصحفي محمد البابا
عذرا ليس مراسلنا ولكن صحفي محمد البابا
لينقل لنا الاجواء من هناك كيف تقول بانها
البدايه
من خلال متابعتك ماذا يعني هذا ماذا نتوقع
بعد
مرحبا يعني القرار الذي جاء بعد جهد من
وزاره العدل الاوكرانيه بالتواصل يعني فتح
جرائم حرب متعلقه بالعمليه العسكريه او
الحرب التي بداتها روسيا على اوكرانيا
وهذا القرار الذي صدر عن المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه جاء بعد عده تقارير يعني ارسلتها
لوزاره وزاره العدل الاوكرانيه بعد
تحقيقات عن تورط يعني الجيش الروسي في
جرائم حرب وعن ترحيل القصري واختطاف
الاطفال خاصه من المناطق التي يعني
احتلتها روسيا تم نقل واحتجاز وخطف كما
وصفه يعني من الجانب اوكرانيا خطف اطفال
تم نقلهم الى اماكن سيتم ومن الخطط التي
يعني تم تداول فيها في وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه ووزاره الداخليه وزاره
الاوكرانيه ان هؤلاء الاطفال يتم اعدادهم
لتغيير العقيده وزرع في يعني زرع افكار
تعود للرؤيه الروسيه لاوكرانيا المستقبليه
وايضا سيتم تجهيز هذا هؤلاء الاطفال
للقتال ضد اوكرانيا وهذه ما تعتبر من
جرائم الترحيل القصري واختطاف الاطفال
وايضا الحكم الذي صدر بحق الرئيس الروسي
القديم بوتين وايضا بحق مفوضه الاطفال في
روسيا والتي تتحمل مسؤوليه او تم تحميلها
مسؤوليه اختطاف الاطفال من اوكرانيا ايضا
الجرائم التي تم يعني تم
اكتشافها من المجازر الجماعيه في في محيط
بوتشا في محيط العاصمه الاوكرانيه وايضا
في اوزيوم هذه من الملفات التي اعدت
اعدادتها اوكرانيا ورفعتها في القضايا
المرفوعه ضد روسيا بجرائم حرب وجرائم
اختطاف اطفال والتي صدرت فيها بهذه
الاحكام ولكن السؤال الذي يتداول الان في
اوكرانيا ما يعني ماذا بعد اصدار هذه
الاحكام هل سيكون هناك خطوات على الارض
مثلا ان تعترف بعض الدول الاوروبيه بهذه
المذكرات مما سيعيد مستقبلا انتظر لنستمع
ردود الفعل من كافه الدول يعني المعلومات
التي وصلتنا ردود الفعل هي من اوكرانيا
مبدئيا وايضا من روسيا التي ترفض كل هذا
الكلام تعتبره لا قيمه له بهذا اعود الى
مراسلنا هناك عبد الجواد لاساله حول
النقطه الاساسيه الملف ليس ملف مقتصر فقط
على الاطفال نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من ملف اخر
منه كما ذكر الصحفي محمد البابا يتعلق
ايضا
اعداد كبيره من المقابر الجماعيه التي تم
الكشف عنها وبالتالي يبدو انه بالفعل
القضيه
فيما يتعلق بهذا القرار هي البدايه فقط
بحسب اوكرانيا وبالتالي هل فعلا تتخوف
روسيا من خطوات اخرى قادمه او لا
ميسون يعني ليست هي المره الاولى التي يتم
الضغط فيها على موسكو بما يخص قضيه تهم
جرائم الحرب والمجازر الجماعيه والمعتقلات
وغير ذلك لكنه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم
اثبات اي شيء من هذا الموضوع طبعا يعني
ميسون لو دخلنا قليلا داخل المجتمع في
البلاد نحن نلاحظ بان المواطن الروسي من
الداخل الذي يقوم بالضغط على الحكومه
والمطالبه بايقاف هذه الاعمال القتاليه
يتحدث عن ضروره المحافظه على المواطن
الاوكراني في تلك المنطقه لذلك طبعا كما
تحدث ميدفيديف ذات مره بان موسكو لن تذهب
لضرب المدنيين هناك وهي تعمل على ضرب
النقاط العسكريه بضربات دقيقه نوعا ما
والا طبعا لكان قد تفجر الواقع بشكل كبير
داخل المجتمع الروسي باعتبار ان المجتمع
الروسي والمجتمع الاوكراني يعني يعتبران
شعب واحد لذلك هي قضيه كبيره لها حساسه
جدا في الداخل الروسي ميسون ولا يمكن بكل
بساطه طبعا حسب رؤيه السياسيين في البلاد
الوصول الى مقابر جماعيه وان يلغى هذا
الموضوع من الاعلام الروسي او من المناقشه
الروسيه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي طيب
اسمح لي ان اعود
للصحفي محمد البابا كونه يتحدث عن خطوات
قادمه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وان كانت
قد تحركت ببعض الملفات ولكنها لم تكن
قادره ايضا على تنفيذ العديد منها
وبالتالي الى اي حد تعول اوكرانيا على مثل
هذا القرار ام انه بالنسبه لها هو دعم
معنوي الان فقط
نعم ميسون ولكن يعني السؤال الذي يطرح في
اوكرانيا عن امكانيه تطبيق وتنفيذ هذه
الاحكام من الطبيعي ومن المعروف انه من
الصعب لا بل من المستحيل تنفيذ هذه
الاحكام في ظل الظروف الدوليه في هذه
الاسماء ولكن ياتي هذا القرار كدعم معنوي
كبير لاوكرانيا وحتى ممكن القول انه في
المستقبل ربما سيكون مثل هذه القرارات
تحفيزا لمنع تكرار ما حصل في اوكرانيا من
جرائم من يعني اعتداء او اعتداء دوله او
او محاوله احتلال دوله لدوله اخرى ما
يتداول والسؤال كما ذكرت يعني السؤال الذي
يطرح في اوكرانيا الان ماذا بعد هذا الحكم
هل سيكون حكم قضائي سوري لا تمثيل لا قدره
لتنفيذه ام سيكون ستكون هناك خطوات وهذا
ما تحاول الان وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
بتحويل هذا القرار الى قرار تنفيذي عبر
قرارات قد تتخذ في مجلس الامن وقرارات
ربما قد تت في مراكز اخرى مثلا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي او البرلمان الاوروبي من عقوبات
تاتي خصيصا او تاتي مباشره على الرئيس
شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر مراسل العربيه من
موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد على هذه المشاركه
وانتقل الى موسكو الان والمحل السياسي
الروسيا بكل صراحه تقول لا قيمه لمثل هذا
القرار وايضا هو بالاصل غير قانوني ولكن
حتى لم لو كان ذلك هو الواقع وحتى لو لم
يطبق اصلا على الارض ولكن هذا لا يمنع انه
مجتمع الدولي يتحرك
بقرارات تطال رئيس الدوله الا يؤذيها
تحيه لكم ميسونه والاستاد للمشاهدين انا
لا اعتقد بان هناك في هذا القرار اي شيء
يؤذي روسيا او يلحق ربما ضربه معنويه او
سياسيه انجاز التعبير
بسمعتها لان هناك عديد من البلدان التي
تدرك
طبيعه هذه الهيئه المسمى
بالمحكمه الجنائيه دوليه تبعتها كهيئه
تعبر او هيئه مسيسه وتعبر عن مصالح اولئك
الذين يريدون القاء اللوم او توجيه التهم
الى روسيا بكل ما يجري في اوكرانيا وحولها
وروسيا بالمناسبه الرئيس الروسي ولادي منذ
سبع سنوات وتحديدا في عام
2016 اصدر امرا جاء فيه ان روسيا لن تصبح
عضوا في هذه الهيئه في المحكمه اي دوله
الموضوع سيد يافقيني ونعرف ايضا انه حتى ق
ضيه تطبيق امر الاعتقال ربما لن ينفذ ابدا
ولكن الفكره هي بمثل هذا التحرك وخاصه في
هذا التوقيت يعني احنا بوقت نتحدث فيه اذا
ما ذكرت بالفعل انها مسيسه بمعنى اخر يعني
انه توقيت الاعلان الان مهم جدا بالنسبه
لكم ما وراء خاصه انه نحن نستمع الى صوت
الصين الذي يتحدث عن امكانيه ان يكون هناك
طرح للملف الاوكراني الروسي في هذه الفتره
انا ليس لدي ادنى شك من ان هذه الخطوه
اصدار يعني مثل هذه الوثيقه
باعتقال الرئيس الروسي ليس لدي شك انها
جاءت خصيص الان في هذا الوقت بالذات لانه
بعد يومين سيبدا زياره الرئيس الصيني الى
روسيا وهذا يعني ربما انا الغربه يرسل
ايضا رساله مبطنه الى الصين التي اذا
تضامنت مع موسكو كليا فهذا يعني ان الغرب
سينظر الى الصين على انه مشارك في ما يسمى
بتلك الجرائم التي يزعم الغرب امام
في اوكرانيا واعتقد بان طبعا بهذا الشكل
او ذاكر ربما سوف يتم التطرق الى هذا
الموضوع قريبا في الاوساط السياسيه او
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه يعني بحيث يتعدى مجرد
رد فعل وزاره الخارجيه وانما سيكون ردا
اوسع وربما
الرد ممكن ان تتبعوا روسيا الان وبالمقابل
اذا ما ربطت هذا القرار بزياره الرئيس
الصيني والمحادثات الموجوده هل لها بالفعل
ان تؤثر او لا وكيف
انا ليه اعتقد انها سوف تؤشر بهذا الشكل
او ذاك على سير المباحثات ولقاء القمه
الصيني حتى اذا تم تناول هذا الموضوع في
اثناء مباحثات موسكو بعد يومين
فلن يتم الكشف عن محتوى هذا الحديث ولكن
واضح تماما ان الصين سوف تواصل الحفاظ على
موقفها كما قيل مرارا وتكرارا الموضوع
وربما النيء بنفسها عن كل ما يتعلق
بتقييمات او تقييم الموقف الروسي ومواقف
اطراف اخرى الصين دائما تلجا الى عبارات
عامه تقول ان هناك مثلا جهود مبزوله من
اجل جعل هذا العالم متعدد الاقطاب ولكنه
لن يوجه مباشره اتهامات الى الولايات
المتحده
عندي نقطه فيما يتعلق
بالطرح الان السلمي او محاوله الصين لان
تكون وسيط الولايات المتحده ترفض هذا
الشيء كليا تعتبر انه اي موقف صيني يمكن
ان يكون سيكون لصالح الجانب الروسي الضغط
الان على الرئيس الروسي هل له ان يدفعه
اكثر الان نحو حتى ولو كان ايمان بما تطرح
الصين او لا سيعرقل الوضع اكثر واكثر
لا انا اعتقد ان ماي من شيء يمكن ان يغير
عصمه الرئيس بوتين على يعني الوصول بهذه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه كما يسمى الى
نهايتها المظفره اي انها الرئاسه الروسيه
وتحديدا الرئيس الروسي عاجم كل العزم على
تحقيق النصر في هذا الصراع في هذه المعارك
التي تجري الان وكهدف اولي وربما احد
الاهداف الاساسيه اقامه السيطره على منطقه
الشرقي وجنوب شرقي اوكرانيا
الرئيس الروسي
ربما عنادا سيذهب الى دوله في تحدي مباشر
للمحكمه الجنائيه تكون قد وقعت اتفاقيه مع
المحكمه او لا انه بهذه الفتره ربما سنراه
يبقى في مكانه حتى تتضح الامور اكثر واكثر
انا لا اعتقد ذلك نحن نعلم مدى الجراه
والشجاعه التي
يتميز بها الرئيس الروسي وليست تبعد انه
سوف يتم كما تفضلت يعني في سبيل التحدي
لمثل هذه الحمله
بجيارا الى بلد ما خارج روسيا وحتى ربما
الى بلد لن يكون مجرد صديق روسي وانما بلد
مثلا يحتل موقفا حياديا اذا هذا الصراع
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
تلبيحات الى ان الرئيس الروسي سوف يشارك
في قمه مجموعه العشرين التي ستنعقد هذا
العام في
في الهند وهذا يعني انه ليس هناك من اي
خوف من حضور الرئيس الروسي الى هذه القمه
التي سوف يحضرها قاده الدول العدائيه
لروسيا منها الولايات المتحده وغيرها من
الدول الغربيه طيب سننتظر لنرى ردود الفعل
فيما يتعلق بهذه المشاركه ولكن دع ني
اتحدث عن الخطوات التي يمكن لروسيا ان
تتخذها في ظل مثل هذه الخطوه صحيح انها
اعتبرتها غير قانونيه ولكن هل يمكن
مواجهتها باي من القنوات الاخرى القانونيه
الدوليه او لا
اعتقد بان هناك ضروره لمواجهتها باي
اجراءات اخرى طالما ان روسيا قالت انها لا
تعترف باختصاص وبصلاحيات غير زي المحكمه
وتعتبر كل القرارات الصادره عنها لاغيه
ليس لها اي قوه قانونيه فلا داعي الى ربما
اضافه اي اجراءات او خطوات اخرى ووضح
تماما ان روسيا لا يهمها اطلاقا اي قرار
صدر او يصدر عن هذه الهيئه التي تعتبرها
روسيا هيئه مسيسه وتعبر عن اراء الدول
الغربيه او كما تسميها موسكو الغرب
الجماعي وعلى راسه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه شيك ترحب بالمذكره هل تتوقع ان
الدول
لن اقول الحليفه ولكن على الاقل التي
اتخذت موقف متوازن ما بين روسيا وايضا
اوكرانيا هل لها ان تندد ان تشيد او ان
تقف على الحياد
انا اعتقد بان اغلب وزاره انها سوف تحافظ
على الحياد وتواصل نفس الاتخاذ نفس
المواقف التي كانت قد اتخذتها قبل صدور
هذا القرار ولن يكون هناك اي تعليق من قبل
هذه الدول انا ليتحدث طبعا ان الدول
الصديقه ودول الوديه وحتى الدول الحياديه
ان صح التعبير لن تبدي رد فعلها بشكل رسمي
اذاء هذا القرار من موسكو المحلل السياسي
الروسي في غينيس شكرا جزيلا لك